[Music]
those smooth sounds they're courtesy of
lola consuelos aka the daughter of kelly
ripa and mark consuelos my beautiful
daughter lola consuelos lula shared the
snippet to social media it's her first
ever single
[Music]
the 21 year old is set to drop the track
titled paranoia silver lining on august
9th and her parents couldn't be prouder
she's beautiful
kelly instagram this sweet pick to
promote the drop while mark tagged lola
in his ig stories for a little promo of
his own it's cool i like it and fans
already seem to be loving it the
comments section on lola's tiktok is
blowing up with compliments
[Music]
the visual is pretty stunning too lola
walking by the ocean a beautiful sunset
in the distance she's sporting a stylish
swimsuit and an oversized shirt as the
slow jam plays
[Music]
now it's no surprise that kelly and mark
are proud of their kid up they've long
gushed over all their offspring lola's
got two brothers 25 year old michael and
19 year old joaquin read you my
anniversary card from my son joaquin
because it is the funniest thing ever
first of all it's written on a father's
day card so that's
so there's that
and we should have seen a music career
coming for lola she's been studying
music at new york university
and
it's one of those things that um
you don't realize how close the younger
two are really close in age and then
joaquin got so like overwhelmed that he
literally fell asleep on her bed
[Music]
back in 2019 kelly and mark documented
their journey of saying goodbye as they
dropped lola off at school the mom of
three captioned a photo of her kissing
lola on the cheek the nest is getting
roomy
while mark shared the same photo writing
two down one to go you two are closer to
an empty nest we are this close we are
truly this close we are down to one we
are down to one kid and by the way he's
in vancouver most of the time yeah most
of the time so i'm truly going to be
running through the house naked i just
want everybody to know that
i'm gonna be sitting on every piece of
furniture naked be warned before you
come over
that's what i'll be doing in my spare
time
[Music]
you